hello chess fans welcome to chess
openings explained i'm nick riscoe your
instructor for the evening and we are
here with our next installment in our
scotch series all about the scotch game
and
this week next week and the following
are going to be the last the last three
parts we're going to be covering some of
the the main moves that black has that
are a real challenge to white
up till this point we've covered a lot
of dubious sidelines from black we saw
we also covered some
wild and dubious gambits from white but
now we're gonna start getting into the
real
uh real scotch lines
and tonight we're gonna be focusing on
the queen moves in the scotch those two
queen moves being queen h4
and queen f6
so let's get right into it here
starting off with our main scotch
position we have e4 e5 knight f3 knight
c6 and d4 the scotch now last week we
started covering what happens if black
takes on d4
and here we get the knight recapturing
in the center
and the first one we're going to go over
queen h4
is a very tough
move to face over the board this is
known as the steinitz variation of the
scotch game
and if white doesn't know what they're
doing
it looks like you're just going to lose
a pawn and the game's just going to be
tough for you
now the move queen h4 has a very direct
threat
you're attacking the e4 pawn
the question that is being posed to
white is how are you going to deal with
this
uh so i'm going to give a second for the
chat to take a look at the position and
actually you guys tell me how you guys
think you should deal with this
if you've never seen this position
before what is your instinct what would
you play in a tournament
if you were faced with this move
i'm actually curious to see
what people think
so queen is attacking
i do want to point out if you're trying
f3
to defend the pawn
this just isn't going to work this f2
pawn is pinned that is an illegal move
so unfortunately that does not work
claus is suggesting knight to c3
okay so knight to c3 does defend the
pawn
the response from black here is going to
be bishop to b4
and the point of bishop b4 is it's
pinning the knight that you just used to
defend your pawn
so if you can give me a little bit of a
follow up here
as to how you're still going to to deal
with this pawn
let's go with that
do we have any other ideas in the chat
i'm not saying knight c3 is bad i'm just
saying i want a little bit more than
just saying knight c3
i guess while we're looking for ideas i
will start covering some of the more
dubious moves
uh with the most dubious probably being
queen to d3
queen to d3 is very simple it just says
hey i'm defending the pawn that is
attacked um but here black can go knight
f6 and in practice black has scored very
well with knight f6 as in they've won
all two games that this position has
been featured in according to the lead
chess masters database
on leeches though the stats are still
pretty good for black with
white mainly trying taking on c6 and
playing knight to d2 as the top two
moves but black is still scoring roughly
58 percent uh and that's 58 win not just
score any points at all
so
uh queen to d3 just not a very practical
move as far as you know statistically
not good responses
just got a subscription from brian felix
thank you for the sub
all right the other move here
that you can try is actually um okay so
we have another guest here bishop to d3
but uh bishop to d3 what are you going
to do against knight takes d4
just a question
kinda
kind of looks like you're down a piece
so i don't think bishop d3 is the answer
the uh the other move that white has is
actually just
ignoring the fact this pawn is hanging
and i believe this is actually the
mentality white should have if black
plays queen h4
defending this pawn is going to be
very difficult and we'll get more into
knight c3 in just a little bit but what
happens if you say all right i'm just
going to lose this pawn i'm going to
play knight b5 instead
knight b5 with the idea of hitting c7
and this is one of the drawbacks to
queen h4 is that as soon as this queen
moves c7 is a weak square
so knight b5 is looking to take
advantage of this
and black has two moves here that they
can try although i think only one of
them
uh
looks practical
um bishop c5
has been played before
but this is the one that i don't think
is
all that great now white needs to be a
little careful they can't just go for
this pawn hoping to get a rook
because the idea of bishop c5 is their
threatening mate so after king d8
there's no way to protect your knight
and to stop the checkmate so you're
going to be losing a piece here you have
to play queen e2 to stop the checkmate
but then king c7 you're down a piece so
unfortunately going for the pawn is not
good enough
however you can develop your queen let's
say queen f3
and after queen f3
uh
okay black can try knight d4
hitting the queen going for c2
um you can also trade on d4 but i'm not
a big fan of this for white
mainly because there's a pretty forcing
continuation here
knight takes c7
king has to move because it's in check
so king d8 hitting the the knight here
and now queen f4
it's offering a queen trade it's still
protecting any potential mates
it's defended by the bishop and it's
also supporting the knight so queen f4
here key move to remember
black should continue with knight c2
check
and after king d1
black is okay to go for the trade
and then both sides will win a rook in
the corner
but now after d6 cutting off the
coordination of the bishop and the
knight so the knight can no longer
retreat
uh white can play knight to c3 and has a
little bit of space but also a little
bit healthier of a pawn structure black
does have this isolated queen's pawn
and seems to be a little bit behind in
development here but this is a
relatively balanced endgame slightly
better for white that i don't think
black needs to to necessarily go for
this
um
this bishop c5 i think there's better
alternatives one of the alternatives um
one of the alternatives to
bishop to c5 is bishop b4 check i think
this one's a little bit more forcing
because you have to respond to this you
can block with the knight or the pawn
but i rather like bishop to d2 this is
also what's been played by
masters in the master database
and at the bishop d2 they they have to
respond to pressure on the bishop
black can also take on e4
white is completely okay to
lose this pawn here
in return for the pawn they are going to
get some rather nice developments like
bishop e2 here and then king d8 black
does need to respond to the fork here if
they try something like queen takes g2
there's bishop f3
and if the queen moves then c7 is
falling
so lots of traps here just need to be a
little bit careful in prioritizing what
you need to defend and what is actually
okay to capture in the moment
so king d8 defending c7
now we get castles by white this also
defends g2
and okay we get a trade on d2 but
white's happy they're developing their
last piece with the tempo
on the queen and now after queen f4
moving the queen to safety you can go g3
hitting the queen and the queen retreats
and this is going to be slightly better
for white you are down a pawn but all
your pieces are being developed and
black is still going to have to worry
about particularly this light square
bishop but also the fact that their king
is stuck in the center it's going to be
a little difficult for black's king to
find some safety here it's not saying
it's totally bad but
this is one of the lines that you can go
for
if you don't get caught in the center
with your king you're up a pawn so
alrighty
uh so that kind of covers the knight b5
sideline here
uh but let's get into the main move uh
knight to c3
so knight to c3
is met with bishop to b4 this is the
most direct move in response to white's
play with knight c3 bishop b4s pinning
the knight removing a defender of e4 so
the e4 pawn is hanging again
so again i'm going to turn to the chat
and ask what you do
in response to this move
bishop b4
what do we do about e4 again f3 is
illegal don't try it bishop d3 just
hangs the knight on d4
how do you respond what should the
mentality be
clause e2 well
what goes to e2 you have four different
pieces that can go to e2
you have a queen that can go to e2 you
have your bishop that can go to e2
your knight on d4 can go to e2 your king
can go to e2
the only one that i see that defends e4
is queenie2
so i don't know if that's what you're
suggesting or if you're suggesting we
uh
well okay we can't do that because like
knight takes d4 right so
uh like
okay
springer is saying queen to d2
claus is saying knight to e2
so let's take a look at these moves uh
knight to e2 why does knight e2 not
exactly work
um well okay the first thing i want to
to check is if black can just simply get
away with taking the pawn
and here it kind of looks like they can
white can follow up with like bishop d2
breaking the pin and now they have to
move their queen but black's gotten this
pawn
so
if that's something you're okay with i
guess you can try knight e2 but even
instead of queen takes e4 what if just
knight f6 black's continuing their
development they're hitting your center
pawn again
uh
you still can't defend it
you can't push it because knight takes
so like this pawn is going to fall black
is like catching up in development
they're getting ready to castle
this looks stronger to me than just
queen takes e4
so knight d to e2
[Music]
i i don't know
um
the other move
is queen to d2
all right we have a lot of suggestions
in the chat here
so queen to d2 here actually is not like
the worst move in the position
but i don't like that you're blocking
your dark square bishop
uh like where is this bishop going to go
and develop in the future
um
you know there there is the point that
if black takes on e4 white is going to
be fine after taking with the knights
and after bishop d2 they can recapture
with the bishop
and knight takes d4 this is fine this is
an even position you can totally go for
this
but black is not required to take on e4
black can play something else um
let's say
what if i just take on c3
um probably taking back with the queen
but now they take on e4 so you're still
losing this pawn
and
okay yeah bishop e3 as an option
defending the knight again
knight to e2
looks okay
um
so again you're down a pawn you're
trading off a set of pieces
it's probably fine
but again i don't like how it blocks the
bishop
all right we have another try of bishop
to d2 first breaking the pin
unfortunately by breaking the pin you
also break the defense of your knight
and they can just capture on d4 so
bishop d2 does not work
yeah oof
but it's okay um
so here
the only move that really leaves white
with a healthy advantage and also scores
very well in the database is bishop to
e2
and
okay nick you're talking about you know
letting this pawn hang but what if
what if black goes for this again they
take on c3 white captures and queen to
e4
well you get a castle and now black has
a couple things they need to think about
mainly what happens if this rook comes
to e1 with the queen and the king
so
um engine here is giving knight d4 pawn
takes d4 and queen bales out on h4
but still like
rook b1 putting pressure on b7 or rook
e1 rookie one is still just very fine
hitting the king
um you really need to like get him out
of here or just um knight e7 is probably
the move here
but all the white's pieces are being
developed this bishop can come to a3
even in the near future
be fine
yeah also very good pointer springer in
the chat saying white has the bishop
pair and that is actually going to be a
very valid form of compensation for the
pawn here as the board is very open uh
black has not occupied the center with
their pawns they're all still on the
second rank
and for what pawns white does have in
the center it's not like so many pawns
that are there that it's interfering
with the bishops in any way so
uh yes very nice point
the bishop pair
does give you compensation
so
um that's the very direct bishop takes
c3 and queen e4
but that is not what black has typically
played um especially since you don't
need to take on c3 right away to take on
e4 so
uh there's two options here i want to
cover i'll cover queen takes e4 in just
a second but very quick there have been
tries where black plays knight g to e7
as well and i want to make sure i cover
this before i forget
so
knight g e7 just developing the piece
looking to castle
well the most direct thing for white to
do here is castle and break this pin
reinstating the connection of the knight
to the pawn and now if black is really
wanting to win a pawn this is the moment
they capture on c3 the pawn captures so
you're not down a piece and now queen e4
now after queen takes e4
white has two options they can go rookie
one or they can go bishop f3 i like
bishop f3 a bit more direct hits the
queen and once the queen
moves to safety on h4
there's moves like knight b5 this is
always going to be a move we want to
keep an eye out for threatening c7 uh
also forcing black to give up his right
to castle
getting the king stuck in the center and
now you can go with something like
rookie one taking control of this open
file and i think here white definitely
has a comfortable position at the cost
of a pawn
but okay we'll get back to it after
bishop e2 queen takes e4
taking advantage of the fact that the
knight on c3 is pinned
how do we continue here
the queen is hitting g2 is this
something we need to worry about
if it's not if we don't need to worry
about queen takes g2
what should we do
as white
hello in the chat polar bear
does anyone in the chat play
the scotch
or maybe you play queen h4 as black
all right we have knight d to b5
okay what is the point of knight b5
and it's just knight b5 the knight on c3
is pinned so we don't need to specify
which knight
but you have this idea of knight b5
what's the point behind it
because you you are just saying you know
like
oh i'm not worried about queen takes g2
all right so
all right uh so the point of knight b5
is to hit c7 very valid point
but you're still not addressing the
concern about g2
again that knight b5 is a fine move but
i want to know what
what your response is to queen g2
we have another guess of just castling
in this position
you cannot forget about your knight on
d4 here
if you just castle they can take they
can take with either piece
there's there's two attackers there's
only one defender so you cannot just
castle
all right awesome so
uh we do have in the chat people getting
the correct solution here that if queen
g2
bishop f3
or you can go knight c7 first
um that's also one of the things i was
hoping someone would mention which one
you play first because you do have these
two different ideas
here in this specific instance it
doesn't really matter which order you
play them but bishop f3 does force the
queen out once the queen is out
you can go knight c6 right away here but
i also really like bishop to f4 this
also maintains the same level of
advantage
and
you don't have to take on c7 right away
they can go queen e6 and after queen e2
queen trade you're in a better end game
c7 is still hanging
but the reason i prefer this is because
you are developing this extra piece this
bishop on f4 which is now going to allow
you to consider moves like castle's
queen side or even just swinging this
rook right over to d1 and there's still
no way to defend c7 so this is one move
that i'm definitely a big fan of bishop
f4
so
yes knight b5 is completely safe to play
not worrying about g2
okay so after knight b5 how should black
respond c7 is a threat
um
let's see if they try something like
queen e5
queen e5 hitting the knight
they can't win it it is defended by the
bishop
not by the knights because of this pin
but like okay let's say they tried queen
e5 hitting the knights
trying to protect c7 what tactic exists
here
i believe this one was actually featured
in an eric rosen video so i will give
him credit for that
queen to e5
how can we punish black for this
someone's seen the video
yeah f4
f4 here hitting the queen now this
may look a little strange because you
are pushing your f pawn forward and as
we know ben feingold one of the grand
grand masters who taught here for a long
time always says never move your f pawn
so
uh what's the point of moving the f pawn
the point here is that there's actually
nowhere for the queen to go that keeps
c7 protected
so
with nowhere to go for the queen
um like
i don't know queen c5 just knight c7
check and you're going to pick up the
exchange with a winning position
um
queen c5 is probably the best move
because it stops white from castling but
this this won't mean anything if white
is up a rook
or rather an exchange the knight is
likely going to get trapped
so
f4 definitely the way to punish your
opponent
so that's why we see in this position
black take on c3 with check
now the only way for white to keep the
initiative here
um they can try taking with the knight
but then queen takes g2 actually is
possible because now after bishop h3 or
sorry bishop f3 and queen h3
there is no knight c7
so you don't have this initiative
anymore
so the point here is um
that after they take on c3 you should
take with your b-pawn and this is going
to be your common theme in the stein
it's variation is that white
is ready to double their pawns even give
up the pawn
to have this attack and now you'll
notice that this trick still exists if
queen g2 is still losing for black after
queen or bishop f3 queen h3
because knight c7 exists at the end
so
having this knight on b5 definitely
helping white out here
and now black has a couple options i
think but um king d8 is the most direct
just
identifying that hey c7 is hanging i
don't want to lose my rook i'm going to
defend
and now i think the play for white
starts to
become a little bit easier
you just castle you defend g2
the knight develops to f6
and now bishop to g5 there's also this
idea of playing a6
and hitting the knight back towards the
center and trading but this i can't
recommend this for black the the doubled
pawns is you know really what white was
fighting against
um
that was sort of giving compensation to
black but here you're undoubling the
pawns
white has the bishop pair they're up in
development
bishop f3 is going to come with tempo on
the queen rookie one on an open file all
these moves are very easy for white to
find and play
without much play from black so
i don't recommend going 8-6 i just
recommend knight f6 completing your
development
and now
bishop to g5 is a very good move here
just pinning the knight
i believe there is a system going around
here with bishop to f3 hitting the queen
first this is also fine bishop f3 is
totally good you're hitting the queen
um
oops
freaking tracy out
moving the board
but okay bishop f3 is another system the
queen moves to f5 and you can play with
c4
and open up this diagonal for the bishop
so the bishop go to a3 you're looking at
possible sacrifices on d6
and after something like 95 you can drop
the bishop back to e2 this is another
way to play for white if you're looking
for something less analyzed
but
bishop g5 does exist and here
uh
one sample line is rookie eight i know
this has been going around on the
internet i'm not a big fan of rookie
eight i don't think this is accurate at
all
because white achieves a very easy
position after bishop d3 the queen
retreats and now queen h5
um taking advantage of the fact the
knight is pinned
if the knight is pinned h7 is hanging
f7 is weak
this knight on b5 is just chilling it's
supported by the bishop
so ricky yates um i i really hope black
never plays that
um and instead just goes d6 and after d6
this is kind of where
i'll leave the position for you guys to
analyze on your own
black has achieved opening the diagonal
for the bishop on the other hand
something like bishop f6 and gf6
can ruin black's pawn structure you make
the claim that rook g8 is going to give
you some compensation
but
right here after d6
i think this is still a good enough try
for black to play for the evaluation is
like plus 0.7 so slightly better for
white but okay if you're not you know
over 2500
really what difference does .7 and 0
make
so
i'll give it just a couple seconds here
in case anyone has any questions about
the steinitz variation otherwise we're
going to get right into the queen f6
lines
so we'll do just a quick review of the
line
just in case there's any questions along
the way we have e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 d4 our main scotch
position
black captures on d4 knight takes and
queen h4 this is the start of the
steinitz variation
knight b5 is a sideline that focuses on
attacking c7
whereas the main line is knight c3
bishop to b4
and bishop to e2 giving up the pawn
for
more development
and so some tricks here with um if black
ever takes on g2
when we have the knight on b5
queen takes e4 taking advantage of the
pinned knight
knight to b5 hitting c7 and if the queen
ever takes on g2 while the knight is on
b5 it's a bad move for black
if this knight is not on b5 white needs
to to be worried about queen takes g2
takes takes with the pawn again knight
on b5 very important
and now king d8 addressing the fork
now we just get natural development
castles knight f6 bishop g5
and d6
and okay i don't see why whites you know
shouldn't go for this maybe if you want
to keep the bishops on the board that's
fine but this is a way they can continue
this is the steinis variation
all right let's move into queen f6
so i thought this was actually very
interesting this is actually um
on the rare occasions that i do play one
e5 as black i will play this variation
mainly because it's a bit of a surprise
weapon i don't think that many people
who play the scotch will have this
variation memorized a lot of their
memorization is probably going to go
towards queen h4 or the two main lines
knight f6 or bishop c5 but queen f6 is
like black's fourth or fifth best move
uh or most played move rather
and doesn't have as much analysis for it
so let's get into that
again our normal scotch position but now
instead of queen h4 like the steinitz we
have queen f6
and as far as i know this one does not
have a name so we're just calling it the
queen f6 line in the scotch
and here white has more than one good
system against this move so if you're
playing this as black
you will need to know a couple ideas
that white has but in general i think
this one is pretty easy to play
at least for the black
side so all right what are some of the
options here
um
why don't we take a look at knight b5 we
just took a look at knight b5 in the
other line how is this one different
well um let's take a look at bishop c5
so in the other line bishop c5 i wasn't
the biggest fan of but here it makes a
lot of sense you're developing
threatening mate in one you have to do
something about it you can't just
capture
again if you capture this pawn
prematurely there's no way to save the
knight and mate
so
um
in the queen h4 line against bishop c5
we had queen f3
but now this may not be as favorable for
white
first off
the trade isn't necessarily something to
be scared of because black does need to
give up the right to castle in order to
do this
but they do have bishop to b6 and black
doesn't have to trade the queens and
white doesn't necessarily want to trade
the queens either if white takes black
is going to be more than happy to
develop their knight so
both sides a little hesitant to trade
off queens first and because white does
not want black to take they they do
typically go queen g3 hitting c7 again
but this is easily stopped with d6 and
you'll notice here
black is not struggling with development
nearly as much as if they want queen h4
you're not gonna have the big uh attacks
on e4 here but
in general i think the position is
opening itself up faster than if the
queen were on h4
so
i definitely want to point out that idea
here for both sides here bishop c5
you can't really go queen f3 for the
reasons i said it's a pretty healthy
position for black the main move here is
queen e2 and this scores very well for
white uh white has uh 48 percent win and
48 percent draw so that leaves only four
percent uh loss
for white tier which if you ask me those
are some pretty good odds
so queen e2 and black drops the bishop
back to b6 again the point of this is to
stop knight to c7
and after bishop to b6 white can develop
their other knight to c3 we have knight
g to e7
bishop e3 hitting this bishop on b6 so
something like uh capturing on b6
captures in knight c7 is a real threat
and the way that black deals with this
threat is bishop a5
might look a little counterintuitive
because you are moving this bishop yet
again
but okay bishop takes b6 was a real
threat
but here
we'll actually see white castle to the
queen side
something that we didn't really see in
the other line the other line was a lot
of castle and kingside and rookie one
this is one of those variations where
you're able to castle queen side and get
away with it and
really
black's best option
probably a6
kick the knight the knight goes back to
d4
there's a trade on c3
and okay your queen side is opening up
as white so this could be a little
concerning but if you look at black's
pieces the knights are really not in a
position the queen also is really not in
a position to take advantage of this
somewhat exposed king there's also king
d2 at any moment if you do need to run
to safety
so you'll see black just typically play
d6 and you'll get natural development
from both sides
um
and
this can be
one of the positions you get so that's
that's kind of this knight b5 idea here
after after queen f6
what are some other
variations you have here
knight f3 is another system that's been
going around
and i think here bishop b4 is the most
played move so this is what i'm going to
look over
bishop b4 you should block with the pawn
get a tempo on the bishop and now the
bishop goes to c5
what is the purpose of including this
check
so so normally if i'm teaching a
beginner about developing their pieces i
tell them you don't want to play moves
like bishop b4 because when they block
with c3 you have to move the piece again
and you're losing time
so why is black willing to go for this
what what is so important that black
feels
giving up this tempo is justified
very nice very nice so it is to block
the knight coming to c3
and with knight to c3 there's a couple
things going on um first that's the most
natural square for the knight the knight
would like to go to c3
ideally go to d5 in the future maybe
knight b5 um like knight c3 knight b5
has been an idea we've been looking at
all night so uh that's one idea and also
knight c3 helps protect e4 so if you
know the knight isn't on c3 protecting
e4
e4 could be a weakness
so i think after c3 and bishop c5
first off don't don't like
please don't play knight d2
just focus on developing the rest of
your pieces bishop to e2 is more than
fine and after d6 black's trying to
develop you can castle king side knight
g to e7
and you have some nice play here on the
queen side with moves like b4
bishop to b6 and bishop g5 so you can
still develop your pieces normally
nothing really special is happening here
the point on bishop h4 is actually
in response to like bishop h3
so bishop h3 is played you can drop this
bishop back and now bishop g4 can be
played so did want to mention that that
is the point of bishop h4 you're going
to drop back to g3 in response to bishop
h3
um but okay uh you just the center pawn
is also up for grabs black has a couple
different ideas here i think a5 is a bit
more serious but again nothing too too
crazy you can defend with the pawn
takes takes if the knight takes on b4
the point of this is that if you take
they win the rook
don't give up your rook just
you take on e7 force their king to give
up its castling rights and you can
develop with something like knight c3
maybe looking to go to d5 in the future
so
nothing
too
too crazy here
so that's kind of your your bishop b5 um
let's see i don't think there's much
variation on this
uh i think they can try h6 here this is
just to stop bishop g5 if they try h6
stopping your natural development
focus on your other natural moves like
castles
and queen c2
queen c2 can be a nice move just to kind
of pass
so
white has to or sorry black has to make
a decision here
queen c2 also helps defend e4
and okay black plays something like a5
you can develop the knight this way
um
you're okay giving up this uh or sorry
making this concession of doubled pawns
so you can get bishop to b2
um but if they don't go for that then uh
you're getting some play on the queen
side otherwise the black castles
you have your normal b4 and a4 pushes
that will
that will get you some play you also b5
in this specific example
so
got some play on the queen side there
i don't think there is much more to
cover with knight f3 here
so what are the other two systems
there's two other systems that white has
here
um
if you go to lead chess and you turn on
the engine and you also open up the
openings explorer you'll notice knight
takes c6 is the top recommendation
um
and here black does have this in between
move bishop c5 they don't have to
capture the knight on c6 right away and
the point of bishop c5 is this this
checkmate pattern we've been seeing
throughout the night so um
don't don't get greedy and think you can
just bring your knight back
uh like night a5 you're you're just
getting checkmated so please don't make
these these mistakes i don't want to see
it
uh you do need to protect your pawn uh
or really protect your king
um so something like queen d2 here
is definitely fine
for
for keeping your king safe you are
blocking your bishop so
uh moves like queen f3 are also possible
but i was looking around and queen d2
wasn't the worst option
black does best just to take towards the
edge of the board
now again if i'm telling my students you
know
how should you capture with your pawns
if there's multiple options normally
you're going to see coaches tell their
students capture towards the center but
this is one of those instances where
if you capture towards the center
um yeah you could probably play d5 but
your light squared bishop is suffering
if it goes to b7 it's going to be
sitting there for a while before you can
play c5 and open up the diagonal and if
it goes to a3
it's going to get snapped off by the
white bishop
so
rather than suffer with problems in
development with your light squared
bishop you can capture away from the
center and now this is actually going to
give you some extra protection when you
castle queenside which is ultimately
what we're going to see black do in this
system
white normally develops with knight c3
over protecting e4
bishop e6 getting prepared to castle
knight to a4
kind of in between move attacking the
bishop so it goes back and
it's safe
and now queen e3 so the point of queen
e3 is not just getting out of the way of
the bishop but after black castles queen
side there is a rook on d8 so
this also gets the queen out of the way
for that
and now black has a couple options but i
thought one interesting option that the
game could continue is queen h4
and after g3 queen h5
bishop d2
now both sides are going to try to
castle queen side and there are a couple
trades that can be made after knight f6
there's something like bishop e2 and now
there's a possibility of bishop g4 but
all this is just
it's not that important to the position
this is just a way that it could go
for both sides and we finish with with
castling here and this is a very
balanced position this is completely
fine for both sides
i don't know who i'd rather have um
because with black you can say you have
some extra safety with the extra pawn
over here with white you can say that
you have a pawn majority on the king
side so
that's that's the debate about this
position
but okay
um other than knight takes c6 there is
one other serious attempt that i wanted
to talk about and then we'll open up the
floor to any questions people have
um
the last system here is the one that i
see the most whenever i'm playing
against it now it's not like i don't
think it's the best system
but the move tried at least against me
the most is bishop to e3
and this is saying okay i have realized
your threat
of taking my knight
i'm just going to defend it
and i'm also going to protect f2 a
little bit
while developing a
piece and black does have a very nice
continuation so i want to include this
line for for black here
is bishop c5
and now really the only way to save the
knight effectively is c3
you can try knight b5 here going for the
pawn but i
i don't know if i can say having the
doubled pawns here is
like
it's a little bit too significant for me
to want to go for c7 here especially
something like queen h4 going for e3
right away
um
or sorry e4 right away
this
is okay
it makes me uncomfortable to see white
go for this because the black queen is
like so active
um
but i guess you can make the argument
this is playable engines are giving it
you know minus one
i don't think it's
it's um
that easy for white to fight back for
equality i think that one does give
white some problems
but white can just say okay c3 i don't
need to worry about any of this
so
uh yeah yeah so someone's mentioning
that they liked the knight b5 system
as soon as they played queen f6 that was
a good system i was just
uh explaining you know what happens if
uh bishop v3 cause bishop b3 is is the
fourth system that we're talking about
so two separate systems
um but yeah it's important not to make
sure you get these knight b5 ideas mixed
up between the different systems because
there are times when it works and then
in this case this time it doesn't
so okay white goes c3 defending the
knight again
this does deprive white's knight on b1
of the c3 square but your priorities
should be
defend this night
black can continue with knight g to e7
looking to castle and then bishop c4
this is just a nice developing move
you're not really doing it to put
pressure on f7 just because it's it's
defended too well but it is a very
active square
and now black does best to continue with
something like knight e5
i do want to mention that
what may look like a trick
knight c6 is actually like really bad
for white
um
here just you can take on e3 right away
even um because it does come with a
threat of mate but also um black doesn't
have to do that they can just capture
with queen and the the bishop is safe
i should have mentioned that the point
of taking was this discovery on the
bishop
um so queen captures c6 is equal but
bishop takes e3 is even better because
now white is forced to double up the
pawns to stop the mate and now
uh black can capture with the knight
this is fine they i mean capturing with
the pawn is also good because now the
bishop opens itself up
i just want to thank you for the sub
uh but yeah uh there are so many good
moves here for black
um
but knight takes c6 probably the best
then you're gonna look for d6 and castle
short
so
if you are the player with the white
pieces while it may look attractive at
first knight takes c6 it's best just not
to play it develop another piece get
closer to castling now the bishop c4
there is knight e5 hitting the bishop
bishop can drop back to e2
and
the reason why we allow this so earlier
i was asking why does black go bishop
check to force the pawn forward because
there was a concession there
why is white okay going to c4
and then to e2 instead of just e2 right
away
right so what like doesn't white save
time by going to e2 right away what what
is the point here
i guess this would be a transposition
into
the main line
i'm not like too familiar with the main
line of the scotch because uh
prepping those over the next week
um but yeah i guess this would
anyways we're getting a sneak peek at
these positions right
yeah so so we do have someone getting an
idea here
that with this knight on e5 there's
actually a possibility we can play f4 in
the future with tempo
so let's say something like queen g6
black may be looking to play this just
to tempo the pawn uh well we castle
and okay if black takes this pawn right
away white is going to be okay by
playing knight d2 hitting the queen and
getting development
knight b5 is also like
probably working here
if bishop b6 i think you can just take
and the only way to defend is by queen
takes
so um rather than just let white develop
freely like this you normally see black
focus on their own development first
with d6
and now you you have a choice as white
you can go f3 or f4 f3s played about
what is that three four times more than
f4 but f4 is also an idea here and this
may be one of the reasons why you go
bishop c4 first luring the knight to e5
to get this
this aggressive move in otherwise you'll
see white play f3
and then after castles something like
knight d2 getting your last piece
developed
and d5 d5 coming through
something like king h1 is fine and if
they take on e4 you can take with the f
pawn
and you have this open file for your
rook
so i just kind of want to show these
systems i think i'll leave this one here
there's definitely more moves here but
i think now we're starting to get into
like mainline scotch stuff which
isn't necessarily the point of tonight
tonight was mainly just focusing on some
of these other systems that are
um
just kind of with you know queen h4
queen f6
but i do want to open up our last 5-10
minutes here for any questions that the
chat may have
about any of these systems if if there's
a line in the queen h4
steinitz variation stuff we can go back
to that
um
or if you have a question on
any of the four
queen f6 systems
i'm happy to answer those questions or
at least try
we'll give it
give it a little bit here we'll do our
short little review and if we don't have
any questions by the end of the review
we will be done
so
we have e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 d4 our
scotch starting position
takes takes and queen f6
the first of the systems we went through
was knight b5 immediately
black's
best move here is like bishop c5
threatening mate and then white just
needs to make sure that they're stopping
the checkmate before they go in with
this attack
this one's probably the best scoring
for white
but you will notice that the the queen
side does get doubled pawns and if
you're not careful
black could attack on the queen side
other than knight b5 the other options
you have are
knight f3
whoa
okay so in this position knight f3 this
is um a less familiar system but it's
starting to make its way around uh with
like 95 or bishop c5
or even bishop b4
but knight f3
i think just follows you know your
natural development
other than knight f3 do you have
captures on c6 where both sides may be
looking to castle queen side
so that's going to be the line where
white has a majority on the king's side
but
you know black has extra defense on the
queen side here
and then our last system that we looked
at for white is if they go bishop e3
which is sounding like it's just a
transposition into the the classical
scotch here
so you have you have this nice easy
system for black
moves that are not too difficult to find
for every or for each side which leads
to relatively equal positions
all right so there is our our summary of
queen f6 lines i don't see any questions
here in the chat so we're going to take
a short break
this was it for tress openings explained
we're going to take a break we're going
to come back with the return of the
winner's circle it's been a while since
we've done one of those but we do have
the saint petersburg tournament which
was the first super tournament
really of chess so we'll get back into
that in just a second see you shortly